I think that that's a very complicated
kind of question because although I
really feel like I never had a
particular obstacle that I had to
overcome as a female scientist I never
felt that I was singled out or or having
anything done against me I do see that
when one looks at where women are in
science that there is a very large
discrepancy and then there there does
seem to be an inability for for women to
get to a higher echelon xin in the
scientific hierarchy or in in academia
so I think that although I didn't feel
like I had any anything done personally
to me I think that there may be more
subtle social interactions at play in
the scientific world that that does have
a little bit of a negative effect on
women advancing in their careers
I think that as more women get into
higher levels of science and as as it's
very clear to younger women coming in to
the field that yes it is possible to get
to the higher ranks that will will help
and also I think that the way that that
women run meetings and when when the
power structure is is such that you have
a larger representation of women at
higher levels that the conversation may
change somewhat and so that could also
be helpful moving forward
just follow what you're excited about I
would say the same thing to female
scientists as to male scientists to all
all young people really the the fun
thing is to be able to do something that
excites you a lot of times what we do is
a lot of hard work but hard work is
actually ok if you really are engaged in
it and so that really i think is that is
the main thing is finding something that
you're passionate about and and be able
to follow that